IS COMING UP FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND IT MIGHT NOT BE
GOOD FOR JAMES COMEY.
IT MAY COINCIDE WITH THE BOOK
TOUR.
>> Sean: ED HENRY.
JOINING US NOW, FORMER BRIGADIER
GENERAL TONY KATO.
ALSO RETIRED INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER DANIEL HOFFMAN.
I THINK WE ARE A LITTLE CLOSER.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S HAPPENING.
YOU KNOW RUSSIA BETTER THAN
ANYBODY.
THEY PULLED THEIR SHIPS OUT.
OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE EXPECTING
SOMETHING.
>> THEY ARE.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF A CIA
OFFICER, I SERVED IN MOSCOW FOR
FIVE YEARS AND THE MIDDLE EAST.
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IS ON
A FULL COURT PRESS COLLECTING
INTELLIGENCE ON RUSSIA'S ACTIONS
RIGHT NOW MILITARY AND
DIPLOMATIC.
AND WHAT THEY MIGHT DO IN
RESPONSE TO OUR MILITARY ACTION.
>> Sean: AT THIS POINT WITH
ALL THE BLUSTER FROM MOSCOW, NOT
PUTIN HIMSELF, WHEN RUSSIA
STARTS PULLING THEIR SHIPS OUT,
THEY OBVIOUSLY DON'T WANT TO BE
COLLATERAL DAMAGE OR INVOLVED.
WOULD YOU SAY THE THREATS THEY
ARE MAKING, MOSCOW IS MAKING, TO
TAKE OUR MISSILES OUT OF THE
SKY, IS IT AN EMPTY THREAT?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK WHAT THEY MAY BE DOING
IS TRYING TO SAVE FACE WITH
SYRIA AS THEY REMOVE ALL
POSSIBLE THREAT FROM U.S.
AIRPLANES, JETS, MISSILES, THAT
COULD BE COMING IN.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY, UNLIKE WITH
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO DO IN THIS COUNTRY FOR THE
LAST 16 MONTHS WHICH IS TO
REMOVE A DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT,
REGIME CHANGE IS NOT OUR GOAL IN
SYRIA.
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING AND WHAT
WE ARE DOING IS APPLYING THE
ELEMENTS OF NATIONAL POWER,
DIPLOMATIC INFORMATION,
MILITARY, ECONOMIC TO ENABLE OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGY WHICH
IS TO ESSENTIALLY PREVENT
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION AND
TO HAVE INTERNATIONAL ORDER
BASED ON THE RULE OF LAW.
>> Sean: ARE YOU BOTH
CONVINCED THAT THIS WAS ASSAD
AND SYRIA?
NO CHANCE OTHERWISE.